[Música]
bons fato
oi pessoal meu nome é ana emília e hoje
eu vou contar uma história pra vocês de
uma ideia que eu tive que era para ser
algo bem pequeno e acabou assumindo uma
dimensão muito maior do que eu tinha
imaginado
primeiro vou contar um pouquinho de mim
meu nome é ana emília nasce em curitiba
e quando eu era criança eu queria ser
diplomata então eu sempre estudei em
muitas línguas e uma delas é o francês
eu estudei cinco anos de francês quando
era pequena
depois eu cresci não virei diplomata
estou me acostumando com a ideia que por
um caminho tortuoso acabei virando
escritora o ano passar o ano passado não
esse ano eu lancei esse livro amanhã
rock que era pra ser uma versão feminina
do livro do meu marido chamado o papa é
pop
infelizmente ele teve tanto sucesso
comercial quanto o livro do meu marido e
eu fiquei dez semanas entre os mais
vendidos na categoria não-ficção logo de
largada já fui teve uma semana de que
fui a terceira é escritora mais vendida
i enfim deu tão certo essa história que
meu editor me encomendou um outro livro
só pra falar de natal
de início eu não aceitei porque eu
pensei poxa eu não sou ser natalino
eu nem sei as a um peru kutner e aí mas
eu gosto muito de escrever eu sempre
escrevi e eu encarei essa história
dentro do meu processo criativo quando
eu não sei mais o que escrever
eu começo a procurar assuntos que me
tocam ou que me deixou muito feliz
ou que me deixam triste e vejo que sai
disso tudo uma questão há como sociólogo
eu tenho um olhar muito atento para a
sociedade e uma questão recente que me
toca muito é a questão dos refugiados
esse mundo de imigrantes chegando aqui
que a gente sabe que eles largam uma
vida que eles têm chegam aqui muitas
vezes não sabe nem falar a língua a eu
vejo eles na polícia federal nas
rodoviárias nos aeroportos
e quem nunca viu um refugiado na rua que
levanta a mão
porto alegre está lotada
só para vocês terem uma idéia eu trouxe
que os dados não é o maior
a maior migração hoje para o brasil vem
do senegal depois da nigéria e depois a
síria
quando a gente fala e refugiado todo
mundo imagina síria guerra aquelas
coisas as pessoas fugindo né de um
conflito mas na verdade um país que não
oferece emprego que não o quer é oferece
uma situação econômica para os seus
cidadãos
esse cidadão quando ele vai para um
outro país ele é ele pode entrar como
refugiado pelo menos no brasil em porto
alegre hoje a gente tem 1.800
senegaleses estima-se e mil e 600
haitianos e dominicanos que é uma língua
que fala francesa tem a ver com o que eu
vou contar pra vocês mas ainda a
respeito dessa sensação que a questão
dos refugiados significa pra mim
na semana passada o filósofo sigmon
bauma ele também já foi um refugiado
polonês lançou um pequeno vídeo na tv
falando sobre essa questão ele disse que
os refugiados simbolizam personificam os
nossos medos porque a gente sabe que
eram pessoas poderosas os seus países
felizes como nós somos aqui mas que hoje
eles perderam tudo perder o trabalho
estão aqui estão assim ainda que o
bairro está falando da inglaterra a
gente está aqui no brasil a gente não tá
tão bem assim
mas de qualquer forma a gente tem nossa
família nossa casa nosso trabalho e
essas pessoas os refugiados eles largam
tudo isso pra ir num país distante que
não sabem a língua não sabe o que lhe
espera
no fundo a gente tem medo de um dia ter
que passar por isso
eu sou mais velozes
então assim eu sou uma pessoa otimista
eu penso que a vida segue uma linha de
encantamento que nem sempre linear pode
dar voltas não é óbvia e pode acontecer
alguma coisa muito maravilhosa desde um
problema a gente pode fazer alguma coisa
que muda o planeta
agora vou contar uma história pra vocês
têm uma amiga que mora na ramiro deve
estar na platéia e um dia me contou que
a gente estava conversando sobre
refugiados ela me contou que viu um
senhor passando e falando como refugiado
na calçada bonjo e o senhor responde
hoje o refugiado foi bom jogo e eles
iniciaram uma pequena conversa em
francês e isso me deu uma idéia na hora
e o que eu não podia juntar três ou
quatro amigas e fazer chamar um
professor de um refugiado para esse
nosso professor eu voltava a falar
francês que nunca mais tinha falado e
ajudava a ele
propus para as minhas amigas fiz uma
pequena postagens no facebook mark healy
sete amigas que eu achei que podiam se
interessar o facebook era fechado e
nessa semana essa pequena postagens em
foto de crianças sem nada que pudesse
chamar a atenção
teve muitas curtidas alguns
compartilhamentos e eu recebi uma penca
de convite de amizade e as pessoas
falavam não consigo comentar na página
dela e me mandando e-mail e todo mundo
manda mensagem eu pensei opa tem alguma
coisa aí tem muita gente querendo fazer
aula de francês
demorei algum tempo pra encontrar um
professor encontrar um lugar e começar
uma primeira linha que encontrou esse
professor foi à margem de uma amiga
minha que era minha colega de pesquisa a
gente passou anos fazendo pesquisas de
tendência conversando com qualquer
pessoa na rua sobre qualquer assunto a
gente sempre fez disso nosso ganha-pão
então a gente tem facilidade de recrutar
pessoas na rua a margem encontrou júnior
fiz uma pequena turminha chamei-o umas
amigas o dinheiro contou as histórias eu
tinha que escrever um livro do natal
lembra disso então o júnior contou uma
história
virou uma história no meu livro tá aí ó
natal no senegal
não vou fazer nenhum spoiler depois no
natal vocês compram belém mas a margem
de nessa aula nessa primeira aula não
entendeu nada ficou apavorada e aí eu
pensei vou ter que ter duas turmas uma
turma das avançadas mais ou menos que
nem eu e outra turma pra quem não sabe
nada pra marjorie para outras pessoas
que tinham se comunicado
então pensei ah quando era otimista a
duas famílias de dez anos maravilhoso
professor vai ser ótimo é uma aula por
semana bem legal
e pra mim vou voltar a falar francês que
era o meu objetivo inicial
nisso eu organizei uma página no
facebook ea maioria postada né divulgou
a página
essa postagem questão de horas em
questão de dias ela teve milhares de
compartilhamentos ea gente começou a
receber muitas mensagens ea gente ficou
realmente apavorada com a quantidade de
gente que queria aprender francês
gente eu nunca imaginei isso e mais
ainda ea coisa mais linda a quantidade
de gente querendo ajudar querendo
participar de um projeto pra ajudar os
refugiados que eu achava que a maior
parte das pessoas era absolutamente
insensível e nem chegava eles que
passava pela calçada e fingir que não
via
e aí foi sensacional só que a gente teve
que sair recrutando muito mais professor
porque a gente percebeu que não ia por
esse só duas turmas de 10 alunos a gente
tinha de repente três mil pessoas
querendo aonde francês
recrutamos mais gente começamos a
conversar com os professores
logo percebemos que não basta falar
francês para conseguir ensinar é
diferente de uma turma de avançado que o
professor é até legal ter um francês
complicado pra gente se esforçar pra
entender não pra quem não sabe nada o
professor tem que ter didática tem que
ter um letramento muito bom conhecer a
língua e uma série de questões que me
fez refletir inclusive sobre educação
como um todo
então recrutamos e fomos à selecionando
os que estavam mais preparados o que não
significa que os outros não possam
entrar num segundo momento
só que a gente precisa ensinar didática
pra eles que vem a gente precisa fazer
várias coisas esse projeto está bem no
começo ainda
esse é um moça um dos nossos professores
às aulas já estão rolando e no começo
todo mundo achou linda essa idéia e
começaram a me chamar pra da entrevista
e televisão e isso excited toque por aí
vai sair no começo não estava aceitando
porque eu tinha medo de não conseguir
fazer acontecer porque tem uma idéia e
prisões quando a idéia influência e
botar em prática existe um caminho
gigantesco mas enfim três semanas eu
acho que a gente conseguiu organizar nos
organizarmos minimamente para botar
essas aulas em prática e aí a gente
começou a entrevista
a repercussão é mais mensagens ainda e
também bom vocês todos devem ter na
internet vocês conhecem essas pessoas né
pessoas hoje que eu tenho tudo que
alguém faz que adoram voltar a sua raiva
contra minorias o contra projetos ou
contra qualquer coisa boa que possa ter
na sociedade assegura vejo este tipo de
comentário racista xenofóbico fascista
eu respondo sabe porque é uma coisa
assim a gente vai responder a pessoa
responder de novo e aí tu vai perder
dias sofrendo com uma coisa que eu não
tenho nenhum minuto pra perder eu tenho
um monte de aula de francês para
organizar sabe para cada reiter vou
dizer pra vocês que acho que tem uns
mais mil pessoas mandando mensagens de
incentivo então mas estão aí né
hoje em dia há boa chance que significa
boa sorte vai dar tudo certo está
organizada mais ou menos assim somos uma
plataforma colaborativa né eu amar júri
ea paola que é doutora em letras e está
nos ajudando com
ensinar didático para os professores a a
gente está focado em treinar os
professores pra eles para que eles
possam treinar outros professores
a gente tem recebido muita duas ofertas
de doação porque ainda nem tô aceitando
nada porque eu não é não me senão eu
estou alugando uma sala no vila flores é
preciso ter um lugar mais fixo
a doação de material computador quadro
negro carteira livros ou tem um cara
mandou se uma caixa com 100 livros de
paris pra gente livros escrita em
francês pra gente trabalhar em aula
empresas me procuram pra eu mandar
professores da aula dentro das empresas
e designers fotógrafos gente é um
sem-fim de pessoas querendo ajudar isso
é muito bonito eu só estou falando vão
bem obrigada
mesmo quando chove então assim a gente
está hoje com 120 alunos quatro
professores têm mais uns três mil na
lista as pessoas não param de me mandar
mensagens
respondo quando consigo atualmente não
consigo responder nenhuma ideia às vezes
nos me xingou até a gente tá dando
treinamentos semanais hoje à noite tem
um treinamento lá na vila flores ea
gente está espalhando essa semente dessa
ideia pelo brasil todo pessoas de belo
horizonte me escrevem curitiba floripa
aqui perto de porto alegre todas as
idades bento caxias farroupilha santa
catarina então eu tô sistematizando
assim o documento dando tudo e é a minha
ideia é mostrar para os outros como se
faz né como que eu estou tentando fazer
eu não sei essa história vai dar certo
mas assim está dando e eu quero
construir um conhecimento conjunto e
principalmente com muita participação
deles
se isso vai dar super certo não sei mas
uma coisa tenho certeza muita gente
soube do projeto e muita gente hoje em
dia quando vê um refugiado vendendo
alguma coisa na rua pensa será que não
tem um professor de francês ali levou os
a oea vai conversar
levou fãs e shane ó
já paulo nesse banco
[Aplausos]